what is the idea behind this uh pawn  advance because it just seems to me to  be lengthening the bishop  um but again oh whoa yeah  it does look like magnus castle he's  just i don't know if he's  sacrificing or he's blundering look at  maxine's face he's leaning forward  white can win a piece right now whoa but  look at magnets he was smiling and then  his face just hit and now he realizes he  blundered  and it's a laugh yeah look at his face  he just trapped his own bishop  his knight retreated taking away the  only escape square the only retreat  square for black's dark square bishop  maxine vasily grav with the last move  pushing a pawn forward black's bishop is  trapped  magnus is losing so wow i can't believe  this is happening  again yeah i mean  yeah absolutely i mean just absolutely  shocking  i mean we did see it yesterday he did  make some careless  one-move blunders well okay  i mean is it fatal david um it's not  fatal it's not the end of the game yet  magnus will try and